Hello, everyone.
So thank you for coming to the Immunotherapy Mechanisms and
Responses Mini Symposium section.
I'm Rob Manguso from MGH and the Broad Institute, and I'm chairing the
session with May Dar from MD Anderson.
Very excited about the session.
I think there's been some really amazing cancer immunology and immunotherapy
work presented at the conference, and as I think most people here can
appreciate, we now are quite sure that immunotherapy is
working for patients with cancer and inducing incredibly
impressive and durable responses in some cases.
And we've moved into a
period of investigation where we're really trying to figure out why it works
and which patients are going to benefit.
And this mechanistic
work can hopefully lead to the development of new, more effective,
and more specific immunotherapies with less toxicity.
So, super excited to hear the talks
today from our speakers.
Just a few quick housekeeping notes about this session.
Each talk is going to be 10 minutes,
with then five minutes for Q&A. Please hold your
questions to the end of each session.
And when you come to the mic,
please introduce yourself
and your institution. Phones on silent for the session.
And, yeah, I don't think there's anything else from me.
So our first speaker is going to be Salman Punekar from NYU,
and Salman is going to talk about some very exciting work using new
IL-2 agonist STK-12 to
combine with pembrolizumab and chemotherapy in non-small cell lung cancer.
So, Salman, over to you.
Thank you. Thank you very much. Good afternoon, everybody.
Thank you for the opportunity. Let me just get things situated.
All right. Very good. Thank you for the opportunity to present new data on
STK-12 in combination with pembrolizumab and
chemotherapy as first-line treatment for PD-L1 negative
non-squamous, non-small cell lung cancer.
Here are my disclosures.
PD-L1 negative tumors account for roughly 40% of newly
diagnosed non-squamous, non-small cell lung cancer and
represent a very significant unmet need.
These tumors respond poorly to chemo IO,
and they are frequently enriched for alterations in STK11,
KEAP1, and SMARCA4, a biology that is characterized
by immune cold microenvironments, low T cell
infiltration, poor antigen presentation, and intrinsic
resistance to checkpoint inhibition.
STK-12 is a recombinant IL-2 engineered to selectively
expand antigen-experienced anti-tumor T cells
while sparing NK cells, naive T cells, and
regulatory T cells, which are the primary drivers of classic
IL-2 toxicity and resistance.
The rationale for this combination is straightforward.
By adding STK-12 to chemotherapy and checkpoint inhibition, we
aim to restore T cell effector function and improve
T cell trafficking within the tumor microenvironment without the
toxicity that has historically limited IL-2-based approaches.
In this Phase I study, we evaluated STK-12 in
combination with pembrolizumab and carboplatin.
STK-12 was administered subcutaneously every three weeks in the
outpatient setting
to patients with Stage 4 non-squamous, non-small cell lung
cancer in the front line.
Importantly, this was a high-risk population by design.
Eighty-nine percent of patients were PD-L1 negative.
The core was enriched for STK11, KEAP1, and SMARCA4
alterations.
Forty-two percent were TTF-1 negative, 22% had
mucinous histology, and 25% were never smokers.
Notably, 22% harbored STK11 and
KEAP1 co-mutations, a notoriously difficult to treat
treatment-resistant subgroup.
Each of these features are independently associated with poor outcomes on chemo
IO. So collectively, this represents a particularly
challenging patient population.
Turning to safety, among 39 evaluable patients,
STK-12 plus chemo IO demonstrated a
manageable safety profile. There were no treatment
discontinuations due to TRAEs, no DLTs, and no
Grade 5 events.
Consistent with the mechanism of STK-12, the most common
toxicity was maculopapular rash, occurring in about half
of patients. It was rapidly reversible with short
courses of steroids or IL-4 pathway inhibitors.
All Grade 4 events,
neutropenia, thrombocytopenia,
febrile neutropenia, and leukopenia, were classic of chemotherapy.
Critically, we observed minimal classic IL-2 toxicity.
There was no significant transaminitis or vascular leak syndrome.
Overall, the safety profile was consistent with what we would expect from
chemo IO alone.
In the overall population, we observed an overall response rate
of 50% and a disease control rate of 97%.
To put this into context, historical benchmarks for PD-L1 negative
non-squamous, non-small cell lung cancer treated with pembro or
cemiplimab-based combinations report response rates in the range
of 23% to 32%.
PFS and OS data are still maturing, but the efficacy signal thus far
is very encouraging, particularly given the high-risk profile of this
patient population.The
selectivity of STK-12 is reflected in its PK and PD
profile.
STK-12 has a half-life of nearly six days, substantially
longer than traditional IL-2, enabling convenient
every three-week dosing.
Pharmacodynamically, we observed robust and sustained induction of
interferon gamma and IP-10,
both of which drive CDA positive and Type I immune responses.
IP-10 is an interferon gamma-inducible chemokine that plays a key
role in recruiting T cells into the tumor microenvironment.
This activation was sustained across treatment cycles, consistent
with the long half-life and ongoing pharmacodynamic
engagement of STK-12.
Equally important is what we did not see.
There was minimal induction of IL-6 and TN alpha alpha,
consistent with the absence of vascular leak and cytokine release toxicities.
This is precisely what we want from a precision IL-2 approach.
Potent immune activation where it matters without systemic inflammatory
toxicity.
At the cellular level, the data reinforced this selectivity.
We did not observe significant expansion of NK cells or regulatory T
cells, and overall lymphocyte counts remained stable.
What we did see, however, was strong expansion of 4-1BB
positive CD8 T cells, a marker of recent antigen
activation,
supporting the hypothesis that STK-12 is selectively
engaging antigen-experienced T cells.
We also observed clear evidence of T cell reinvigoration,
demonstrated by robust proliferation of PD-1 positive
CD8 T cells.
Importantly, the majority of these cells were CD28 positive,
indicating a co-stimulation competent memory-capable
phenotype, not just proliferation of terminally exhausted
cells. So this is not broad, indiscriminate immune
activation. This is targeted engagement of the effector
component
of cells most relevant to anti-tumor immunity.
At the clonal level, T cell receptor sequencing provides further support
for the selective, yet robust immune response.
We observed clonal expansion, including greater than tenfold expansion
of preexisting clones,
and importantly, the emergence of numerously previously
undetected T cell clonotypes.
After just one cycle of treatment, 3.5% of circulating T
cells were derived from newly expanded clones,
suggesting antigen-driven remodeling of the T cell repertoire.
Critically, the degree of clonal expansion seemed to correlate with clinical
response, directly linking these transitional
findings to efficacy.
I'd now like to focus on two subpopulations defined by alterations
in tumor suppressor genes.
Half of efficacy evaluable patients harbored at least one alteration in
STK11, KEAP1, or SMARCA4.
These three genes are located in close proximity on the short arm of
chromosome 19, are frequently co-altered, and are
associated with metabolic reprogramming and impaired immune function.
In this subgroup, we observed an objective response rate of
61% and a disease control rate of 100%.
This is particularly noteworthy because these tumors are
characteristically non-inflamed,
with reduced T cell infiltration and impaired antigen presentation.
Published data report response rates in the single digits to low
30% range, with median progression-free survival of three to five
months.
And importantly, the activity we observed here was in a subgroup that was
overwhelmingly PD-L1 negative. Fourteen of 18
patients were PD-L1 negative, and the remaining four had PD-L1
expression of just 1%.
Drilling down further, we enrolled eight patients with
STK11/KEAP1 co-mutated non-small cell lung cancer, six
of whom were PD-L1 negative.
This population represents approximately 10% of
non-squamous, non-small cell lung cancer and constitutes one of the
highest unmet needs in the frontline setting.
Historically, response rates are in the single digits to low teens.
Forty percent of patients progress on the first scan, and median
progression-free survival is approximately only three months.
With STK-12 plus chemo IO, we observed a response rate of
50%, and no patient experienced progressive disease on their first
scan. In this co-mutated subgroup,
the median progression-free survival was 5.5 months, with two
patients still on treatment.
The six-month overall survival rate was 88%, with median
overall survival not yet reached at a median follow-up of 6.8 months.
We acknowledge the sample size is small, but these
results appear meaningfully different from historical benchmarks.
To our knowledge, the only available Phase III data in this population comes
from the subgroup analysis of IMpower-150, which reported
a median PFS of three months and a median OS of 5.4
months across pooled treatment arms.
When we examine the translational biology in the STK11/KEAP1 co-mutated
population, the story becomes even more compelling.
At baseline, these tumors showed reduced proliferation of
antigen-activated CD8 T cells, consistent with their
immunosuppressed phenotype.
After treatment with STK-12, proliferation of 4-1BB positive
antigen-activated cells was restored.
We observed a marked increase in proliferating PD-1 positive CD8 T
cells and robust clonal T cell expansion.
So even in this highly immunosuppressed setting, STK-12
appears to reengage the immune system and restore functional T cell
responses.Given that these tumors often carry high tumor
mutational burden yet remain unresponsive to checkpoint
inhibition these data suggest that STK-12 may be
capable of reversing underlying immunosuppression
in summary STK-12 demonstrates consistent and selective
immune activation robust T-cell engagement and encouraging clinical
activity across multiple treatment-resistant subgroups
STK-12 has the potential to convert immunologically cold
into responsive ones addressing a major unmet need in first-line
non-small cell lung cancer
with a manageable safety profile and strong biologic rationale these
data support continued development a randomized phase two study
synergy is currently enrolling
thank you very much we'd like to thank everybody who contributed to this study
from the patients to all of the staff
Thank you, Selman. For questions, please come up to the mic.
Selman, maybe I can start with a question.
So I think
one of the most
common things that people have noticed in prior IL-2 cytokine-based therapies
is systemic toxicities, and this is a partial agonist.
Is it the receptor biasing for what it binds that is responsible
for the separation of efficacy and toxicity here?
Yeah, I'll just point you towards the
right here. So in the bottom right-hand side, you can
see how it
is biased towards activating antigen-activated T cells, but not necessarily the NK
cells and the CD28 cells. So most of the toxicity that we see
is with cytokine release and vascular leak.
And then the induction of Tregs results in a lot of the
resistance to IL-2-based approaches.
And so you lose that therapeutic window when you use traditional
IL-2.
Okay. I also have a question follow-up to that.
So you showed really nicely that there's no expansion of NK cells and Tregs in the
peripheral blood. What about in the tissue?
Did you see any increase in NK cell population following your
treatment or any increase in Tregs?
So that's a very interesting question, something that we'd like to study.
We don't have on-treatment and progression biopsies, unfortunately, in this patient
population, so we're limited to the periphery.
But that's definitely something that we'd like to demonstrate in future work.
Selman, I have one more since nobody is at the mic right now.
I feel like maybe I can just take all my questions.
Please.
This is an engineered cytokine variant.
How different is it from IL-2 in amino acid
conservation space? And is there an immune reaction against the
cytokine? Have you looked for anti-drug antibodies against it?
I can't answer the question as to how similar of an amino
acid sequence it is. I don't know the answer to that.
I actually-
Three amino acids.
Three amino acids. There we go, so-
Only three amino acid changes.
Yeah.
And presumably you have looked for anti-drug antibodies, or
no? Because obviously in engineered cytokines,
neutralization is a problem that people would consider.
Most IL-2s, even aldus looking, see some antibodies
typically after continued dosing.
So we see after cycle six, eight, and so on, we see
antibodies, but concentrations and biomarkers are still very active,
so they're probably not neutralizing.
Very interesting. Thank you, guys.
Okay. Thank you very much.
Okay, so now we move on to our second talk, which
is going to be delivered by Dr. Meilin Li from Houston
Methodist. It's going to be focused on tertiary
lymphoid structures and how they define response to durvalumab,
trastuzumab, and pertuzumab combination in HER2-enriched early breast cancer.
Hi.
Good afternoon. Thank you to the ACR organizers for this opportunity to
share our work. My name is Meilin, and I'm a sixth-year MD, PhD
student in Dr. Jenny Chang's lab at Houston Methodist Research
Institute. And today, I'll be presenting our study on tertiary lymphoid
structure-associated immune circuits and how they define response to
durvalumab, trastuzumab, and pertuzumab in HER2-enriched
early breast cancer.
I have no financial relationships to disclose.
So to orient us, I'll start with the clinical challenge of de-escalation
strategies for HER2-positive breast cancer, introduce our DTP
clinical trial and PCR outcomes, share some interesting cell
types that we identified on our single-nucleus RNA sequencing
data and how these cell types relate to one another in our Xenium
data, then conclude with some interesting findings.
So HER2 positive breast cancer is increasingly defined by biologically
guided treatment. Historically, HER2 positive breast cancer,
like triple-negative breast cancer, was considered an aggressive disease with
poor prognosis. This changed in the 1980s with the
identification of the oncogenic function of HER2 and
the eventual development of anti-HER2 targeted therapies,
including monoclonal antibodies, tyrosine kinase
inhibitors, and more recently, antibody drug conjugates.
In parallel, intrinsic subtyping has refined our understanding of breast
tumor biology.
HER2 positive disease is clinically defined by HER2 protein
expression seen on immunohistochemistry or gene
amplification on fluorescence in C2
hybridizationHowever, the HER2-enriched molecular
subtype is defined by gene expression, often by bulk RNA
sequencing. So while these categories overlap, they're not
equivalent.
Despite this, the progress in preclinical and
translational research,
chemotherapy remains the backbone of treatment with toxicities such as
long-term neuropathic pain and cardiac dysfunction accepted as
unfortunate but unavoidable side effects.
So when immune checkpoint inhibitors showed great success in triple-negative
breast cancer, we and others became interested in whether
immunotherapy could be adapted for HER2 positive breast cancer.
And this led us to ask, if HER2-enriched tumors are
especially dependent on HER2 signaling, could we omit
chemotherapy for this subset of patients and treat them with
immunotherapy and anti-HER2 targeted treatments
alone?
And this led to our clinical trial using durvalumab, an
anti-PD-L1 immune checkpoint inhibitor with trastuzumab
and pertuzumab, two anti-HER2 targeting antibodies,
collectively called DTP, as a chemotherapy-free regimen.
For DTP, we screened 51 HER2 positive hormone
receptor-negative patients, 45 of whom were HER2 enriched.
Thirty-nine patients began the clinical trial with us, and 37 of them
completed the trial and were included in the final analysis.
All patients underwent baseline clinical exam and imaging with either
ultrasound or mammogram. And after six cycles of DTP,
we repeated the clinical exam and imaging, now with MRI, to assess
tumor response.
Patients with adequate tumor reduction proceeded to surgery and pathologic
evaluation.
Patients without adequate tumor reduction
received standard of care salvage chemotherapy with
docetaxel carboplatin, trastuzumab, pertuzumab,
abbreviated here as TCHP, and then went to surgery.
One of our readouts was pathologic complete response, or PCR,
defined as residual cancer burden, RCB, of zero, meaning
no invasive tumor was seen on the surgical specimen.
DTP alone achieved a PCR rate of 49%, which
increased to an overall of 54% when including the
patients who were salvaged with TCHP.
We sequenced treatment-naive needle biopsies from all 37
patients but focused our analysis on the 31 patients treated with
DTP alone.
And using single-nucleus RNA sequencing, Xenium 5K spatial
transcriptomics, and multiplex IHC, we wanted to figure out
what cell types were present in our samples, how did they correlate with
clinical response, and how are they spatially organized.
And in our cleaned-up single-nucleus data set, we analyzed around
500,000 total cells, including 170,000 immune cells,
which clusters here in this UMAP broadly into B, myeloid,
NK, plasma, and T cell populations.
We then reclustered each lineage at higher resolution and annotated a
total of 23 T and NK cell clusters,
18 myeloid dendritic cell clusters,
and 13 B and plasma cell clusters. And this led us to
ask, okay, now that we've done all this work, which of these cell types are
associated with response?
And while there were many, we focused on these three, these T follicular
helper like CD4 positive T cells, LAMB3 positive
mature dendritic cells, and cycling B cells.
These subtypes were significantly enriched in treatment-naive
tumors from patients who eventually achieved PCR, shown here in
blue, and depleted in patients who later had substantial
residual disease, shown here in red.
But are these significant cell types acting independently, or are they organized
as part of a broader immune program?
And to answer this question, we used hierarchical clustering of cell type
abundance and co-occurrence across tumors to identify five
immune modules, shown here by the colored labels along this heat map.
In one of these modules, module two on the lower right, contained the
same T follicular helper, B, and mature dendritic
cells we found in our previous analysis.
And overall, this module as a whole also strongly correlated with
PCR.
Because these cell types were enriched individually and within the same immune
module, we thought they might reflect tertiary lymphoid structure, or
TLS organization.
TLS are organized immune aggregates that form in
non-lymphoid tissues, including tumors, and support local
adaptive immune responses.
They exist along a maturation spectrum from these loose
aggregates into organized structures with B and T cell
specific zones. And mature TLSs can also develop
germinal center features and function like local mini lymph nodes to
support antitumor immunity.
But sequencing only tells us which cell types are present, not where they are.
So to test whether this module reflects TLS organization, we
move on to spatial transcriptomics.
We ran Xenium on a subset of patient samples and transferred over our
single-nucleus cell type labels.
Here we can orient ourselves with the H&E image on the left and the
corresponding Xenium image on the right, with nuclear staining in blue,
cell boundary markers in magenta, interior protein in green,
and RNA in yellow.
We can also zoom in on one particular region or structure shown on the lower
left, and then see which cell types from our single-nucleus annotations are
present, shown on the right.
We can also see the same region, now one cell type at a time,
including our previously defined response-associated
populations.The T follicular helper cells
here in purple are mature dendritic cells here in yellow and
then a spectrum of B-cell populations on the top in red.
We also find some other canonically associated TLS subtypes, including
interspersed CD4 and CD8 T cells,
plasma cells, and supporting stroma cells, including reticular
fibroblasts and lymphatic endothelial cells.
Next, we ask how to quantify these response-associated interactions
in our spatial data.
For this, we defined a niche as a spatial co-occurrence of a
CD4 positive T cell, a B cell, and a dendritic cell
within a 20-unit radius.
Here in the middle, these maps show the spatial distribution of these
niches in black across each patient's needle biopsy.
On the left, we then quantify niche abundance across response
groups.
And overall, patients who achieved PCR after DTP
had higher percentages of tumor-infiltrating lymphocytes and more
of these niches based on niche fraction.
And finally, on the right, CellChat analysis suggests that T
follicular helper cells are supporting B-cell activation and
maturation through pathways including IL2, CD40,
and ICAM.
So in summary, TLS immune organization defines response
to DTP in HER2-enriched early breast cancer.
We find that distinct immune cell subsets, including T follicular
helper-like CD4 positive T cells, LAMB3 positive
mature dendritic cells, and B-cell populations associate with
response to nivolumab, trastuzumab, and pertuzumab.
We also find these populations to form a coordinated immune module that
correlates with pathologic response.
Spatial profiling further shows these cells to organize into TLSs
across maturation states. And finally, TLS-associated
niches are enriched in tumors from patients who achieve PCR and may help
identify candidates for chemotherapy-free strategies.
And with that, I'd like to thank the patients and their families for participating
in the study, along with our clinical and research team,
collaborators, and funding sources for their support.
Thank you very much, and I'm happy to take questions.
Thank you for a wonderful talk. Jan Kidrowski from University of Illinois at
Cancer Center. Did you find any evidence of formation of high
endothelial venules?
Oh, yes. Excellent question. So as you can see here, we
have, as I mentioned, the supporting structures.
In our stroma population, you can sub-cluster
endothelial cells into arterial, venule, HEV-like, and also
lymphatic. So for this,
I grouped together the lymphatic and the high endothelial venule cells,
and they're in green. So yeah, they do exist.
So treatment induced these populations to higher levels
or to different states?
That is a great question that we have not yet investigated
because all of our samples were based on pre-treatment.
So our goal was to figure out which of the immune responses or
structures could predict for a response. So all of these are treatment naive.
Oh, I see. Okay.
Yes. But we do have post.
That requires a lot more time and data analysis.
Yeah.
Yeah. But very fascinating to look at.
That would be good to separate out the lymphatic and the venule populations-
Yes
... because they're doing different things. Thank you.
Thank you.
Aakash Patnaik from University of Chicago. Great talk.
I was wondering about when you stratify your
RCB0s to, let's say, the tumors with residual
cancer burden. Do you see
within the TLSs a difference in, let's say, proximity
to macrophages or myeloid cells? Or have you done spatial
analyses to understand the basis for
the response versus lack of response?
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
Oh, sorry. I think I missed the question.
So the question is-
Did we see other cell types?
Yeah. In the non-responders or the incomplete responders, did you see
other
close proximity to macrophages, myeloid cells, and other cell types that may drive
resistance?
Yes. Actually, that is a fascinating question.
So when we did this initial analysis...
Okay, so based on all of these cell types, we had a lot of significant
cell types that were correlated with response.
And so we grouped together these specific ones,
including the PD-1 positive T follicular helper cells.
Some other interesting ones that correlated with response were, for example,
PD-1 positive exhausted T cells. And then anti-correlated
with response/maybe predictive of resistance were
SPP1 macrophages. And then now that's a
separate story that
I
don't know if they're going to intertwine or not right now.
But when I went to a lot of talks at ACR, there's a
lot of myeloid-mediated suppression.
And so some interesting ones would be the SPP1 macrophages.
We also have the TREM2 and the full R2-positive
macrophages. When I
do the label transfer and then look at where these populations are,
the majority of them are in the tumor.
So TLSs are
outside of the tumor, and there's some
interesting organization happening with MDCs at the
tumor stroma interface. But these macrophages,
SPP1 particular, are primarily in the tumor.
So I think there's another interesting story, but I need to do some further
analysis onto which cell types I want to include in the niche. Does that help?
Yep. So they're in the tumor, but close to the TLS or in some
proximity.
Maybe to refine my
conclusion is that TLSs, we often see when their TILS are
greater than 10%. And this we know by univariate regression.
So mDCs and T follicular helper cells happen when
there's more TILS, but if they're lower TILS, then they actually shift to a
different dendritic cell population, and then I think the immunology changes a
little bit. But we're working on that. Thank you.
Wonderful talk. Seems that all your questions are coming from Chicago.
I'm Fotis Makropoulos from Rush and the Anderson.
So,
fantastic data. I wanted to ask a couple of things,
short questions. First of all, your
CD4 population
Mm-hmm.
Does it have other canonical markers for follicular
helper-like cells, like ICOS? Are they fully
characterized? And the second thing is,
with your dendritic cell component there,
do you see dendritic cells that are not LAMF3
positive, like XCR1-positive dendritic cells that are not as
mature as
the population you highlighted?
Yes. So for this, I'll answer with some caveats.
One of which is our single-cell data is very deep,
and we have around, I think, 17,000 probes that are giving us the
genetic diversity of all of our cell types.
But then when we go to Xenium, we only have 5,000
probes. So you are kind of squashing the
complexity of the data. And so in our single-cell subtypes,
we do have multiple dendritic cell subtypes.
That's why there are all these islands, and then here would be
CDC2. Actually, I can show you right now.
CDC1, CDC2 here. We have type 1 and type 2
interferon-responsive monocytes, lots of macrophages as well,
mDCs, cycling dendritic cells. So these are all very interesting.
But then the issue is when we label transfer to our Xenium,
we don't have as much complexity, and that's why the dots are kind of
sparse. You could also argue that you don't need a lot of these cell types
to present antigen or to stimulate B or T cell responses.
Does that answer your question? Okay. Thank you.
Okay.
Fantastic. Thank you so much for a very interesting talk.
Okay, our next speaker is going to be Hongchang Fu from the Francis Crick Institute
in London, and he's going to tell us about how nonsense-mediated decay
inhibition can enhance antitumor immunity.
Thank you, Dr. Margusev, for introducing. So my name is Hongchang.
I was a former PhD student at University College London, and now I'm
a postdoc at the Francis Crick Institute.
And today I'm very glad I can have the opportunity to present our latest
work on inhibiting nonsense-mediated decay to induce in
vitro and in vivo and ex vivo tumor immunity, or antitumor
immunity. This is my disclosure. None of these are to do with the
study I am presenting today.
So immunotherapy has really transformed treatment outcome and treatment
regimens for many patients with cancer.
However, vast majority of patients do not respond.
And what we know about a response is that one of the best predictors to the
immunotherapy response is the number of mutations that a tumor has.
However, only less than 10% of tumor really features a high tumor
mutation burden. And our question really remains, how do we
benefit the remaining 90% plus of the tumor with low tumor
mutation burden?
And on top of that, what we know about a mutation is that not all mutations are
really equal. And our previous study has shown that some classes
of mutations are correlating better with immunotherapy response,
and this is frame shift mutations, FS indels, which has the
potential to translate to highly non-self and immunogenic peptides.
However, it always introduce the formation of premature
termination codeon, which then leads to the degradation by the NMD
pathway and leading to no antigen formation.
So what is an NMD pathway? In a setting where the PTC
is formed in the middle of the transcripts, the ribosome will stop translating
at a PTC, and this will lead to the activation of the NMD
pathway, resulting in the decay of the mRNA.
And for the time being, I will not go into the details.
We know that the NMD is efficient, but it's not perfect.
Some transcripts do escape the NMD
pathway. Our prior study has demonstrated that
the NMD escaped FS transcripts do correlate with the better
clinical benefits because those are the ones being presented to the
immune system and being recognized.
Inevitably, they will be under negative selection because they are being recognized
by the immune system, and there wouldn't be any selections for the
NMD-inducing transcripts because they are never expressed.
And that suggests there will be an untapped pool of
highly immunogenic neoantigens.
And given those, we hypothesize at a DNA level, we're able to find,
FS mutations. And then at RNA level, there are associated PTC
transcripts, and then we express them into FS proteins,
load it onto the MHC class 1 complex on the tumor cells,
being recognized by the T cells, get activated, and leading to
successful tumor cell killing.
So in order to do this, we have firstly to identify a successful
inhibition target to inhibit the NMD.
To do this, we correlate nine biological and clinical parameters to rank
all the NMD-associated genes. And
SMG1 appears to be the top-scoring candidate.
And SMG1 is a kinase that phosphorylates the NMD
complex, and which features promising inhibition
targets for this study.Next, to see if such an
inhibition strategy have a clinical impact, we have employed a
preclinical model called a patient-derived tumor fragment model.
This is a novel class of preclinical model that preserves the
tumor ecosystem as well as the tissue architecture.
There has been study that demonstrates the ex vivo response from the
patient-derived tumor fragments correlates with the clinical response from
patients receiving anti-PD-1 therapy.
In our cohort, we have formed a N equals to 15 samples
derived from patients with colorectal cancer.
And most of those features a proficient MMR status, which means
that they feature
low immunogenicity and low T cell activation.
So the way we do this is to inhibit the SMG1
in ex vivo with SMG1 inhibitors.
After 96 hours, we assess the activation by high dimensional
flow cytometry.
And what we observe is a significant increase of a T cell activation,
as represented by PD-1 positive CD8 T cells.
However, such an activation was not observed on the normal adjacent
tissue, which confirms the tumor specificity of such inhibition
strategy. In parallel, we have also performed
single-cell RNA sequencing and TCR sequencing.
What we observe is a significant upregulation of cytotoxic
molecules as well as T cell expansion.
So we see this PD-1 positive CD8 T cells being increased.
So we wanted to know if this actually sensitized the immunotherapy response.
To do this, we have employed a very aggressive
immune refractory tumor model called Lewis Lung Carcinoma.
What we can observe is single agent SMG1 inhibition has
achieved comparable tumor control
to single agent anti-PD-1 therapy, and combo therapy has achieved
superior tumor control than any other single agent
therapies.
What has been fueling this T cell activation and
tumor control is the activation of CD8 T cells,
as represented by PD-1 positive CD8 T cells, in line
with ex vivo results. In addition to that, we can also see a
significant increase of the T cell activation on CD4
non-Treg population. This is co-expressed with
a range of co-stimulatory molecules as well as T cell clonal
expansion.
So what we observe is a T cell activation, but we don't know what this T
cell is seeing and the molecular basis behind that.
To do this, we switched to cell lines.
After inhibition, we can see a
upregulation of a range of PTC containing transcripts and
in
silico translation has demonstrate the SMG1 inhibition leads to
upregulation of neoantigens and induce a high TMV-like
state in the cell lines.
After performing the immunopeptidomics, we have identified a unique subset
of peptides that they only upregulated upon the NMD inhibition.
And all of those are predicted to be the NMD inducing ones, and which
indicates that the SMG1 inhibition has stabilized these NMD
inducing transcripts to be degraded.
And here, I am showing you two neoantigens arised from
a same transcript.
So we have identified these neoantigens, but we don't know if they are immunogenic.
To do this, we have performed in vitro priming by deriving the dendritic
cells and mature them, pulse them with the identified peptides, and co-culture
them with naive T cells.
After two rounds of priming, we restimulate the CD8 T cells
with the identified peptides. And as you can see here, four out of the
six peptide we've identified has shown comparable immunogenicity as
one of the standard model antigen, NY-ESO.
So we know the antigens are immunogenic, but in this system, we
don't know if they are NMD inhibition dependent.
To do this, we have modified a previously reported reporter.
One is degraded by the NMD pathway, and that
induces higher NY-ESO expression only upon the NMD inhibition.
And the other construct, called NMD negative, that
escapes the NMD degradation, and that induce constitutive
NY-ESO expression regardless of the NMD inhibition.
After that, we transduced both constructs into the cell lines,
and then co-culture with the T cells that recognize the NY-ESO antigen.
And then assess the immunogenicity via flow cytometry.
What we can see here is the NMD inhibition actually promotes the T cell activation,
but it's only being observed in NMD positive, but not in the NMD
negative, suggesting such an activation is in a NMD
inhibition dependent manner.
And not only that, we can also see such an activation is
also antigen dependent, because when we block out MHC class one,
such an
activation is gone.
And on top of that, we can also see that the SMG1
inhibition promotes also the T cell mediated tumor cell killing, as
evidenced by a significant reduction on the relative cell growth.
And very last but not least, I hope I have convinced you with our story that
we identified several FS mutants and then get these PTC
containing transcripts expressed, and then translate them into
FS-derived proteins, get them loaded onto the MHC class one
complex on the tumor cells, being recognized by the T cells,
eliciting a successful immune response, as evidenced by our
MHC class one dependent T cell activation evidenced in in
vitro, in vivo, and ex vivo model systems.
And at very last, this is a huge collaborative work.
I would like to thank everybody who's been involved in this work, especially the
patients and their carers and all of our collaboration labs who's been involved in
this work.
Thank you very much for your attention, and I will be very happy to take any
questions.
That was a great talk, Hongjun. Maybe I can ask the first question.
Oh, we have a question. Yeah.
I was also going to say that was a great talk.
So is the MND pathway pretty ubiquitous across all different
cell types or inflammatory
conditions? And does it ever target viral
mRNAs that are being translated?
So it's a
pan-mammalian eukaryotic RNA
surveillance pathway. So it's being presented in all tissues.
But what we suspect is that tumor cells relies more on the NMD pathways than
normal cells because they need to handle the higher mutational burden.
So in an evolutionary perspective, the tumor cells will rely more on the NMD
pathway.
For any particular reason?
Well, from evolutionary trajectory, I guess, because when a tumor
needs to evade the tumor immunosurveillance, they need to down-regulate all
these neoantigens in order to escape the
immunosurveillance.
Okay. And so if there's an infection, would it be upregulated, for
instance, out of the tumor setting?
Well, I don't think I can give you an answer to this question, but
we do encounter this problem when
identifying the clonal expansion because when we do this...
Sorry.
So when you see the clonal expansion in our ex vivo results, we actually filter out
the viral reactive clones in order to get us a clear signal.
Okay, thank you.
No worries.
Hi. I had a question about your LO2
results, like in your mouse model.
I was wondering what your dosing regimen was of your treatment, and why do
you think that control is coming in at a later stage?
Does it just take a while for those transcripts to build up?
So I can't remember the exact days in my head, but I
think
every Q4, I remember, and then we wait for the tumor to grow
and then starts the inhibition strategy.
Thank you.
No worries.
Hongjun, I have a question.
So,
I think it follows very logically that SMG1 inhibition would cause the
expression and presentation of frameshift-derived
peptides, and that these could be immunogenic.
But you show actually in an ex vivo organoid model
that-
Yeah
... that NMD pathway inhibition acutely increases
T cell activation.
Yeah.
And the way I'm thinking about this
is that for that to work, there would need to be pre-existing CD8 T
cells that already react against those antigens.
There would not, in that organoid system, I feel like, be time to prime a new
response in that timeframe. Do you think this is
the right way to think about it? And how do you think this is working?
I really appreciate this question, Dr. Manguso. This is a very great question.
We actually encounter a lot of analysis within
the PDTF work.
Because we have more datas which I haven't shown, is the source of such an
activation was coming from the T effector populations that's
pre-existing in the T cells. And this actually demonstrates a
recall response because NMD itself is a leaky pathway.
As I stated, it's not 100%
accurate, so some transcripts do escape.
But what we think is there may be some
transcript that escapes the NMD pathway, but later on
gets detected. So there are already primed clones against these
transcripts. And I would like also to acknowledge actually the
limitations of the model, the PDTF model, because it's a
monoculture. So a lot of analysis was precluded by
this monoculture, because if we really need to elicit a prime a new
response, we would need a
lymph node and a fully systemic immunity that's been connected.
I think it's very interesting actually, that you're seeing that there may have
already been priming against leaky expression of the transcripts.
That's a pretty interesting insight in and of itself.
Thank you very much.
And I have one last question, if the audience doesn't have any more.
What would
you speculate, or if you have seen any toxic
effects of the SMG1 inhibitor on normal cells, and
how do you see this strategy being translated to the clinic if
there is some toxicity on normal tissue?
Thank you very much for the good question.
Because we have this really good flow of having from
bioinformatics and validating through different preclinical models.
I think before, if this were going to a clinical trial, I think first thing is
very correctly
pointed out is the toxicity. So if we really need to initiate
this, I think first of all is the preclinical data we've shown.
Here because theoretically, NMD was
more being dependent by the tumor cells, so that already
confirms the tumor specificity. But since it's a
pan-eukaryotic pathway, if this inevitably will target the
normal cells. But throughout the different models, for example, in ex vivo,
we've seen more significant activations in the tumor cells rather than in the
normal cells. And you see such an activation, this is not presented in the
normal cells. And then later on in the mouse studies, we actually did a weight
loss
analysis as stated in the paper, and we don't experience significant weight
loss, which suggests the safety of this drug.
And even worse come to worst, I think the dosing strategy also
needs to be tuned down, so that, for example, in case if you
see such toxicity in the patients, we would dose it down to the level that
it still elicits the T cell activation on tumor cells, but not in normal cells.
Excellent. Thank you so much.
Thank you very much, guys, for the attention.
Okay, so now moving on to our next talk.
We have Kerry Daniel MacDougall from MD Anderson Cancer
Center, who's going to be talking to us about a diet trial, which was a
randomized double-blind dietary intervention study in melanoma patients
receiving immunotherapy.
Hello, all. Thank you for having me.
I'll be presenting today on behalf of our amazing team, the
results from our dietary intervention delivered in parallel
with standard of care immune checkpoint blockade.
So I've nothing to disclose.
So hopefully, many of you are familiar with our prior work that has
now been also shown by many other groups that the microbiome is
predictive of response to immunotherapy in patients with
melanoma. We have also found in our cohorts that dietary
fiber intake at baseline or when patients are starting to initiate
therapy is also predictive of more durable responses
and improved progression-free survival.
We've also shown this with our colleagues at NCI, that dietary
fiber in mice given a fiber-rich versus a fiber-poor
diet delayed tumor growth after anti-PD-1
treatment. So building off this very exciting
observational data and pre-clinical data, we set
forth to do a dietary clinical trial in this
population.
And of course, most people can recognize that this is a very
difficult undertaking, and yes, it is challenging.
But the fact is that all of our patients have to go home and eat something,
and they actually are very highly motivated to do what it takes in order
to improve or optimize their therapeutic experience.
And fiber-rich foods, in my mind, really provide
access for the microbiota to multiple accessible nutrients that it
needs within a single bite. I also
hypothesize that the diet supports symbiotic
relationships between gut health and host health because we evolved
on our diet, and our microbiome evolved with us on that diet.
I also think that food-based approaches can be very agile to address inter
and intra-patient variability. Again, because it's a multi-pronged
approach versus a very targeted, single supplement
approach. And I think that if we think about all these things
combined, we can thoughtfully design these kind of prebiotic
food-enriched diets that will mitigate some of the stress that the microbiota
and the host go through during therapy.
And so I just wanted to orient you to this randomized,
double-blind, isocaloric dietary intervention study that
is delivered in parallel with standard of care immune checkpoint
blockade. And I wanted to also emphasize that this is done across
three different cohorts, so you'll see this when I present some of the
data. And we have an equilibration period followed
by the two randomized diets. Now, all
calorie-containing meals and snacks are provided to
participants throughout the study, and it is matched to their energy
needs and macronutrient controlled so that patients
also aren't supposed to know what arm they are on.
So this is an example of what a typical day would look like when it's received by
the patient.
This is dietary fiber intake as it's ramped up over time.
I don't know if this works. Yes, it does.
In the very beginning, you'll notice this is their usual dietary fiber intake
before they enter the study in the screening period.
They go on an equilibration that's meant to bring them all to the same point where
they all receive the control diet, and then the high fiber arm is
ramped up over time according to the patient's tolerance from 30 to 50
grams per day.
And this is where the randomized diet starts.
And I just wanted to parallel that with these are gastrointestinal
symptoms that are monitored in the patient.
And you can see that, of course, the dietary fiber arm is experiencing
a little bit higher burden, not significantly higher burden, and that in
both arms, this decreases over time.
So it's a very tolerable intervention if we think about other
strategies that could be used in this setting.
So what we found in the gut microbiome was not these overall community
effects. We didn't see shifts in alpha or beta diversity, but we did see
enrichment in different individuals of different response-associated
taxa. So again, these are response-associated taxa seen in our
cohorts and across many other cohorts across the world.
This has been well-studied. So these are really compositional shifts that are
a little bit person-specific. So going back to what I said about
maybe food helps us deal with this variability.
We also saw some functional changes in the serum bile
acid pool. And in targeted bile acid analysis, we saw
a decrease in the secondary to primary bile acid ratios.
So these shifts in the bile acid pool and these ratios are
increasingly linked to anti-tumor immune response, reflecting
the host microbiota interaction in preclinical
models, and we're starting to see it also in some of our human studies.
And this was presented by Janie in a poster yesterday, if you want to go
ahead and see more of that data.
Our clinical outcomes were an exploratory outcome.
Again, we had multiple
cohorts, and so we're looking at this largely in our unresectable and neoadjuvant
cohorts, but we had a dramatic difference in our response rate, change
in target lesion, and we saw that these response rates were seemingly
durable responses in terms of event-free survival and
recurrence-free survival in this cohort.
And we presented data with about a year back of follow-up, very early data
ASCO last year, and these are updated
findings with an additional year of follow-up.
So again, coming back to the gastrointestinal symptoms, we looked at both
diet and ICB attributable adverse events.
And we saw that there was potentially a lower
burden in the high fiber arm, or at least comparable, but we
also saw a significantly lower rate of cutaneous toxicities in the
high fiber versus control arm, and you can see
specifically what those
were.So
remember that plot that I showed you where dietary
fiber is sort of converging in the screening period during the
equilibration, and then they're moving on to the randomized
diet. So this is the pretreatment sample, and then right after
this period, they go on to the randomized diet.
So it's very interesting that this sort of mirrors what happens with their intake,
maybe just shift over one week. But this is our
CyTOF data looking at classical monocytes, and of course, this is an
immunosuppressive cluster of monocytes.
And we're seeing that this is lower or decreasing over time.
In fact, they're flipping after initiation of the randomized
diet. And of course, we're also seeing when we're looking at responders and
non-responders in our trial, we're seeing that pattern that these
classical monocytes are associated lower
with immunosuppression.
Looking at our digital spatial profiling data, this is a representative
image from a complete responder patient in the
neoadjuvant cohort. And then, of course, pre-intervention versus
post-intervention, it was complete response, so we had no tumor.
We're looking within the tumor bed in these samples, and you
can see that we had quite an interesting effect here.
And then I'll show you a little bit of the quantitative data from that.
So in the complete responder patients, we saw the CD8 T
cells, of course, are higher
in patients that respond at screening versus end of
interventions you would expect in a complete responder.
But this effect is far more pronounced in the patients who are in the
high-fiber arm. So that's this group right here.
We see a similar effect for cytotoxic lymphocytes.
And then, of course, in the non-responders who did not respond to immune checkpoint
blockade, we really don't see these differences between pre
and post or by arm. And then looking at the pathway
analysis, we see a very similar pattern in terms of the
immune response.
So giving a very quick summary of the overall findings of the
trial, again, this is a high-fiber diet versus a healthy control
diet. Both of these diets meet cancer prevention
guidelines. They do not contain processed meats.
They do not contain lots of junk food. There is nothing like that.
But they do contain-- They're omnivore diets.
They do contain meat, and they use high-fiber
foods, real food, in order to increase the difference between the arms.
And so through that alone, in parallel with standard of care immune checkpoint
blockade, we feel that we safely and effectively targeted the following
things. So gut and host metabolism, we saw favorable shifts in
different response-associated species and shifted the circulating
bile acid pool. We saw favorable shifts in circulating monocytes
and cytotoxic immune cell populations in the tumor microenvironment,
and we saw numerically higher response rates and survival
that seemed to correlate with the immune signals that we are seeing.
And most importantly, we saw a comparable safety profile in the two
arms, and we potentially saw some lower rate of cutaneous
toxicities. So we do not have this all figured
out. This is a schematic from another group that we're continuing to
understand how this is all coming together.
And a lot of this will be done in our preclinical models, where we're taking FMT
from the patients and putting them into mice, and we'll really be able to look at
the time course of some of these events.
And this is work that is continuing to be ongoing.
So
we basically saw that a high-fiber diet is good. So who cares about that, right?
We already know that's good for us.
Well, actually, it's really hard to optimize this in the oncology
setting. And so let's think about what oncology patients
also have to think about in terms of clinical nutrition.
They have to emphasize calories and protein.
There are certain micronutrients they're often deficient in that are more easily
attained from animal foods. So we want to emphasize this is not
necessarily a vegetarian diet that we are testing.
This is a high-fiber diet. But also, we did see the patients
struggle to eat the full meals throughout the study.
So we know that we're going to be adjusting this approach going forward.
And that's exactly what we've done in our current trials.
This is ongoing work, and we now currently have a prebiotic
food-enriched diet trials open in the neoadjuvant and the metastatic
setting where we're using that sort of small meal approach, still working to
target the microbiome and improve outcomes in our patients.
So thank you so much for listening. I look forward to your questions.
This presentation is now open for questions.
Yep.
I have two questions. One is, did you track the caloric
intake at all? Just because if it's high fiber, you maybe have more bloating,
fullness, and-
Yes. So every week they met with the dietitian.
So first of all, the menus are designed for each patient to be
isocaloric, so to match their calorie needs.
So we calculate what their calorie needs at baseline, and then we actually
adjust it every week if they're losing weight.
So we're trying to maintain weight, and then each arm is doing
that. So we're doing it all with an isocaloric
model. It's not exactly like a mouse because they can choose not to eat what they
don't want to eat. But we do provide all the meals in a
menu that is matched to their energy needs.
And then they're monitored each week for intake, body weight,
and they meet with a dietitian if they're struggling with exactly what you said.
Okay, and then the second question is,
what would happen-- I know you don't know, but what do you think would happen if
you did
just psyllium fiber supplementation instead in addition to-
Well, you're asking a nutrition person, and I'm going to tell you that I've been in
nutrition forDecades now. Gosh.
And we've done a lot of supplement trials in the cancer prevention setting, and
they never mimic what we see with diet in the large observational
studies. And the reason why is because food does
not contain just one thing. So in the food, there is
obviously different prebiotic fibers.
There is resistant starch, soluble fiber and insoluble fiber, inulin,
pectin. All the things that are being studied one at a time are all
contained within food in a combination with amino
acids, with phytochemicals, with other things that all probably have some
kind of synergistic effect that we think the microbiome is
actually quite well-adjusted to dealing with.
So
I may be biased, but I don't think we would
achieve the same effect with even a combination
of supplements, because again, it's going to have to be agile over time.
Okay. I didn't mean to imply you didn't.
No, this is my favorite question.
Do you think it matters if they're fermentable fibers or not?
Or just within the food mix that if you only-
Right. So both soluble and insoluble,
if you want to say insoluble would be fermentable fiber and resistant starch,
all seem to have effects on the gut microbiome.
So yes, we're interested in these particular taxa that specifically
ferment fiber and produce fuel for all
the other microbes in the gut. But there also
seems to be effects either through the gut microbiome or perhaps
other metabolic pathways for soluble fiber on bile acid
metabolism and resistant starch on things like other
metabolic effects. Resistant starch is one of the things people use to mimic
GLP-1, for example. So in high fiber
foods, there's a combination of all those things.
So I think that
some of it could be fermentable, but I think we can't ignore the other
components that could be having an effect.
So for mechanism,
that will make it challenging to tease it out.
So we always have to remember what the
intervention was and know that we're holistic effect
in terms of being able to tease that out.
But,
I certainly look at those studies to think about what foods to select and how
we design these interventions.
Yes, great talk. I was wondering about the neutrophil
cytotoxicity score that was enriched in the high
fiber cohort. I think you had that in your app there.
Is it this one? Mm-hmm.
Yeah, the top immune gene ontology on the right.
And I was wondering if the shift in microbiome
with the high fiber diet, is that only in the gut or actually
in the tumor microenvironment that could-
Right.
- originate through neutrophils.
This is the tumor microenvironment.
Yeah.
This particular.
Yeah. I was just wondering if the microbiome change is actually
happening in the tumor in addition to the
gut. That could explain-
Ah.
- neutrophil-
Microbes in the tumor.
Yep. That could explain-
Yeah
... why you have more neutrophil-mediated cytotoxicity.
Just kind of a-
Oh, absolutely
... hypothesis question kind of thing. Yeah.
Yeah. So I think that is definitely another area that we're going to have to look
into. Again, we do have some limitations in terms of we don't
have a lot of non-responders in the high fiber arm who are
neoadjuvant patients that we have those tumors in,
and vice versa, we don't have a lot of responders in the control arm.
So I think we'll continue to look at these in some of our cohorts.
So we'll use this data to look at some things in our larger cohorts that we
have and, of course, continue to look at that in ongoing trials.
But I agree with you that there's probably interaction between
microbes in the tumor and what's happening with the host immune response.
Absolutely. Thank you so much.
I have one quick question before we close.
So
have you followed patients long enough to know after they
get off the diet and go back to their
regular diet that they follow-
Mm-hmm
... do you see the immune benefits that you saw on the study
revert back or?
Okay, so what we do have is we have-- So nobody's able
to do this, what we're able to do, 100% on their own.
Maybe some of them are able to continue maybe at 10%, 20%,
or they go right back to where they were.
We're really trying to get them through that critical period at the beginning of
their immunotherapy that we think is so important to their response.
And if we had a billion dollars, we'd keep them on it forever.
But we are seeing that this improved
survival is sustainable over time, and we're
looking at the IREs both acutely during the
therapy and long-term over follow-up.
And it's really quite promising. We're not trying to get too
excited because of the sample size, but we're obviously
thrilled we haven't turned it in the other direction, but it seems to
be beneficial, which is great to increase response
without increasing toxicity, right.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
This was very interesting.
Thank you, Sarah.
Okay. Our next talk is Jingyao Zhang from Danbury Hospital and
Hofstra, and she's going to tell us about how IL-17,
Th17 cells drive IL-17 dependent
neurotoxicity
in the CNS.
Good afternoon, everyone. I'm Jingyao from Danbury Hospital.
I'm a PGY2 internal medicine resident in Conn LA
Care. Today, I will present our study in CNS
immune-related adverse events or
IRAE-CNS.
So, in this project, we wanted to understand what is
actually driving these cases at the immune level and
whether that biology might point us to a more
targeted treatment
pathwayI don't have
any disclosures.
So first, I want to start with the clinic questions.
So
IRAE-CNS is rare, but when it happens, it can be
very serious, and the patient presentation can
be very different, and the timing after immune
checkpoint inhibitor treatment can be very difficult
to predict. And other change is that even
many of the cases are clearly inflammatory, but
the patient don't really always responds well to the
steroid. And
even though we know this is an important toxicity,
we don't have a good understanding of the intracerebral
immunobiology. So that lead to our central question,
is there a disease-specific CNS immune program that
may explain disease severity and point us to
a targetable pathway?
To answer this question, we use the
longitudinal multi-center cohort.
So for the first three cohort, were really
for the discovery, so
where we use the
multi-omics to define the immune landscape.
And in cohort four, we moved into translational part
where we use the multi-center
real world cohort and tested
anti-IL-17A treatment. And also patient
had a serial PET scan, brain function test, and a follow-up over
time.
The first question we asked was whether
IRAE-CNS has a distinct
inflammatory protein signature, and the answer was yes.
So what we found was this is a
disease-specific
inflammatory protein
patterns, which including the
protein
signals including CD137, IL-17,
MCP1, MCP4, CCL11, and granzyme B.
And what's more interesting is those protein level
correlated with original PET scan signaling, and
especially in the area like limbic
system. So
this really suppose this is not a descriptive biomarker.
It's
not descriptive. It seem to be active
tracking with intracerebral inflammation.
After we saw this
inflammatory protein pattern, the next question we ask is
which cell are actually
producing it. So using the single-cell approaches, we
identify a distinct
polyfunctional cell cluster,
and we named it as a POLR6 positive
cells. It cause secreted the six inflammatory
mediators I mentioned earlier. And this maps to
an activated CD3 positive, CD4 positive,
PD1 positive helper T cell state. And so at
this point, the story becomes more specific.
We're not just describing the inflammation.
We identify a candidate
pathogenic cell population.
Then we ask whether the cell are
clinic relevant, and what we found the POLR6 positive
program is strongly associated with IL-17
biology. And also patient with a higher POLR6 positive
burden correlated with higher
neuroinflammation in PET scan, and the patient with more
POLR6 positive
cells have worsening cognitive and neurologic outcome
over time. So
these cells are not just there.
It seem to be tracked with the disease severity and the prognosis.
So then we wonder, is this something
temporary inflammation response or something more
persistent? What we found is the phenotype is very
stable from onset to 12 months, and
dominant T cell clones
kept showing up during the follow-up,
mainly in PD1 positive, CD137
positive effector memory CD4 positive T cell.
So this really supported this is an
ongoing antigen driving immune response rather
than a short-lived
inflammation burst.
Okay.
That naturally lead to our next question.
So
what are those cell reacting to? So among the
neuroantigen we tested,
NMDA R1 clearly stood out. It's the
primary target recognized by reactive T cell
clones and with strong signal over the time.
We also saw most NMDA R1 reactive helper T cells
are POLR6 positive.
At this point, the model is
this gave us more concrete mechanistics for
the disease. Then we ask whether NMDA R1
reactive T cells are associated with a worse clinic
outcome. And again, the answer was yes.
So patient with CD137 positive NMDA
R1 positive T cells are associated with increased
neuroinflammation in PET scan and worsening
neurologic and cognitive function in brain function
tests. And soThis
is an MDAR-specific poly-6 positive
T cell driving disease, and these are also associated with the
patient doing clinically worse.
Finally, we ask the translational question, if
IL-17 is a central downstream
signaling, can blocking it actually help the patient?
So in a propensity match real world cohort, we
found that the patient who were treated with anti-IL-17
therapy had improved neural inflammation in PET
scan and also the
brain function test.
And so this really point to that
the IL-17 treatment
targeted the
pathway in this disease process.
Also important in our analysis, we
did not see a significant difference in
cancer-related or overall mortality in patients treated
with
anti-IL-17 compared with standard of care.
And just to wrap up, there are three take-home
points. First, IRAE-CNS
is marked by a disease-specific
CD137 positive, PD-1 positive,
poly-6 positive helper T cell state in CSF,
and these cells are persistent,
clonally expanded, and neuroantigen reactive,
and with a strong bias toward an
MDAR1. And also IL-17 is
the most actionable downstream signal, and
anti-IL-17A emergence as a rational
therapeutic strategy. So our
model is a neuroantigen reactive poly-6 positive TH cell,
and drives IL-17 dependent
neurotoxicity, leading to measurable imaging
abnormalities and cognitive injury, and
associated with targetable biology.
I will end by
acknowledging some limitations of the study.
Even though this is the largest IRAE-CNS series to date,
our individual cohort are still relatively small.
So CSF sampling give us an accessible window into inflammation,
but of course, it's not the same as study the inflamed
brain tissue directly, and our antigen screening was still
limited. So based on the limitation, we would like to validate the antigen
more broadly and link CSF finding to tissue level,
say, as immunopathology, and the possible test, the
IL-17A blockade perspective in a randomized
clinical trial. So I would like to thank the patients and the family
who participated in this study and our collaborate
centers and the study
team. And especially, I would like to recognize
Dr. Yifei Ma, who is the first author of this study
and whose dedication make this study possible.
And he cannot be here to present this project
by himself, so I'm truly honored to present on his behalf.
I'm happy to take any
questions.
Thank you very much. This presentation is now open for questions.
I think we might have a question in the back.
Hi, I'm Steve Blum from Mass General. It's a really great story.
I was curious a little bit about your antigen screening.
Did you go with only a handful of antigens, and you ended up finding
exactly the right one? If so, how did you narrow that down?
And was I interpreting it correctly that even in your control T cells, you had
some that might have been responding to those antigens, or was I misunderstanding?
Yeah. So for the antigen screening,
our antigen screening is kind of
limited. So we screened
five neuroantigens,
as I mentioned earlier,
but the MDAR1 was the one which was dominant
and clearly stood out in our study and which
caused the reactive T cell, and yeah.
That's great. And I apologize. How did you get to those five, and what did you do
to define antigen reactivity?
So that's pre-defined, so I don't have a clear answer
for that.
So I think that's something we pre-defined
because this autoimmune encephalopathy, which is
associated with MDAR1, and also the five
antigen we pre-defined. So that's one of the limitations.
Yeah.
Got it. Thank you.
Jing Yao, I have another question.
Mm-hmm.
I didn't actually catch the cohort
makeup. What are the cancers that are
in the cohort, and is there some association with
diagnosis? Are there brain mets here as
well that you happen to see?
So brain mets is clearly excluded from our study.
So for any-
Excluded?
Yeah, it's excluded
from our study, so for the brain mets.
And for the cohort, all the cancer type are mixed.
We have all different cancer type. We have non-small cell lung cancer.
We have gastric cancer. We have lymphoma.
Because, as I mentioned earlier, IRAE-CNS is rare, so
wherever the patient had
we suspect the patient has IRAE CNS will be
included. So the cancer type was kind of
mixed. And for the cohort, as I mentioned, we have four
cohort. And,
yeah, so the control group is not only non-IRAE CNS,
we also has autoimmune encephalopathy,
and we have CNS
infection. Yeah, we have different
control group. Yeah.
Got you. And the other question I had was about the IL-17
intervention. These patients were on an IL-17
blocking antibody because they had autoimmune disease, and you were able to sort of
retrospectively look at them?
Yeah.
Or this is something that you guys did based on your finding?
So for this observation study, I would
say, so it's not after we have this
autoimmune encephalopathy, and we know this
anti-IL-17 would be effect for
some of the patient with especially we know autoimmune
arthritis, and this is
central signaling. So that's why those patients are on.
But those patients were not on before. Yeah, I would say, yeah.
I see. And do you have an explanation for how it's
reducing CNS inflammation? That antibody presumably doesn't cross into
the CNS.
So yeah, that's a great question. So we only found that
NMDA R1 was a dominant antigen,
but we don't exactly know what initiate the
events and, yeah.
Okay.
Thank you, Jingyao.
Thank you very much.
Okay. And now,
I think this is our last talk of the session.
We have Dr.
Junyoung Wang from City of Hope, who's going to talk to us
about NAT10 MEK loop and how it induces...
Sorry.
There's one more after.
Oh, there's one more. Okay.
The
penultimate talk in the session. Sorry about that.
So we have, as I said, Junyoung Wang
from City of Hope, who's going to talk to us about NAT10 MEK loop and how
it induces immune evasion and immunotherapy resistance in
CRC.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, everyone.
I sincerely thank ACR for selecting our work to
present today. It's a great honor for me because at least maybe my first time
and maybe my last time to share my work,
and it's very pleasure for me. And also sincerely thank
our session chair for kind introduction. Thank you very much.
And sincerely thank Dr. Ajay Goel and all my
colleague in our laboratory, and our whole
collaborators
give me so many support and help. So my name is Junyoung Wang
from City of Hope. The title of my presentation today
is "NAT10 MEK Group Induce MHC1 roles
through Autophagy to Promote Immunoevasion and the
Immunotherapy Resistance in Colorectal Cancer."
I have no relevant disclosure here.
So let me start with the clinical challenge.
As we know, immunotherapy has been the major breakthrough
in cancer treatment. And
the real problem is in colorectal cancer, most of the
patients cannot benefit from the immunotherapy.
They represent as the microsatellite unstable
or proficient mismatch repaired.
We called MSS or MMR colorectal cancer.
This is the dominant form of colorectal cancer
account for more than 85% to
92% of colorectal cancer are MSS, and the most
of these patients are largely
checkpoint blockade resistant.
So when we think about where a real unmet need is,
I think this is clearly here. So to address this
question, Dr. Jinnie and the colleagues develop common sense
molecular subtype, we called CMS, including
CMS one, two, three, four. This framework help us
to better understand the
different feature of the different colorectal cancer subtype.
Among them, CMS two is especially important for our work
because CMS two represents the largest
fraction of colorectal cancer. And more than
98% of CMS two are MSS, means most of these
cancer are resistant to immunotherapy.
And they are very interesting. They have
strong MEK activation and present as immune
desert, and poor immune
infiltration, and the poor expression of HLA.
So,
in our work, we were interesting to identify
the tumor selective and drugable regulator
in immunoevasion. So in recently,
RNA modification has gained the main focus in cancer
research,
including M6A, M7G, and AC4C. Among
them, AC4C has gained more and more attention,
with so many
high impact study published in very good journal, like "Nature
Science Cell" in least two years. And NAT10 is
the
main write of AC4C modification.It's known to
regulate the mRNA stability and the translation, and
can be targeted by remodeling. And Nitin
was also associated with tumor progression
and immune discretion.
But
the role of Nitin in immunotherapy, immune evasion,
especially in colorectal cancer, is largely unknown.
So based on this, we put out our hypothesis is that
Nitin is a tumor's intrinsic driver of
immune resistance in MSS colorectal cancer.
And we have three questions: what, how, and why?
So this is our three Ms. The first M is establish
the clinical significance of Nitin.
The second one is identify the underlying mechanism.
The third one is explore the upstream regulator of
Nitin.
So first, we check across the public
data, and we have two independent clinical cohort.
One is from Fudan University Shanghai Cancer Center from China,
and another clinical cohort is TMDU from Japan.
All this data show that Nitin is
significantly upregulated in
CRC compared with the normal tissue.
And the more important thing is upregulated
Nitin was correlated with worse survival.
And here also have very important data and very interesting data
that
Nitin was significantly upregulated in MSS
tumor. This tumor was resistant to immunotherapy.
So based on this, we hypothesized that Nitin was correlated
with MSS, so maybe they have some relationship with
the immune cold phenotype. So we check
across the TCGA data and our sequence data.
We analyzed this TME. So Nitin high tumors
show lower immune score and the estimate score.
This indicates that Nitin
high tumor has a cold
TME, and we use IPS to predict the response to
immunotherapy. Also, Nitin high get a lower response.
And SSGSEA analysis indicated that higher Nitin
get a lower T cells and the CD8 T cell
infiltration. Also impaired the HLA-MHC1
function and also impaired the checkpoint
therapy response. So based on this, we
hypothesized that Nitin correlate with
MSS type and also the immune cold
phenotype. So next, we check whether Nitin is functioned in
the immune evasion. So
we perform the Nitin knockout in the mice
competent cell model. We found that after knockout of Nitin,
significantly suppressed the
growth of the tumor, and also
knockout of Nitin increased the infiltration of CD8 T cell, and the Nitin
knockout enhanced in vivo T cell killing.
So here, Nitin knockout can increase
the number and the function of
CD8 T cell. So
CD8 T cell is so important for Nitin, so we check
the role of CD8 T cell. So
we perform a CD8 T cell depletion mice model, and
this match our hypothesis that CD8 is the main mediator
of Nitin. And
it's most important result data support our hypothesis
that Nitin knockout can significantly
increase the anti-PD-1 therapy, and the
complete tumor regression
in up to 80%.
And that we check the Nitin depletion,
showed that after knockout the Nitin, the TNF-alpha
positive and IFN-gamma positive T cell also increase.
So I think everyone was curious how Nitin
functioned. So Nitin, we use across the TCGA
database and the RIBO-seq database.
We identified that autophagy is the key pathway
during this process. And
ATG3, ATG5, Beclin 1, MIKE, may be the candidate
Nitin targets. So how autophagy contribute to
immune evasion?
So here we check the
Nitin RIBO mRNA stability analysis.
We found that Nitin increase the stability of the target
genes, and finally,
elevate the autophagy flux in CRC cell.
So how autophagy contribute? We check that
after brokering of autophagy,
MHC1 expression increase,
and also knockout the Nitin, the surface
expression of MHC1 also increase, and the list confocal
show that OC3 and HLA have a
significantly colocalization in CRC.
And this WTA analysis showed that
knockout of Nitin can increase their antitumor
protection in a...
tumor
challenging mice model. So last question is why
NIT1 will increase in the MSS tumor?
So we checked their public data in our clinical cohort
that MYC and NIT1 was positive correlated with each
other and especially in CMS2, MYC and
NIT1 was coordinately upregulated in
CMS2. And we found that it's very
interesting that MYC transcriptionally active NIT1, and
then NIT1 can stabilize MYC mRNA stability
through AC4C modification. So there's a MYC-NIT1 loop
exists in CRC. So finally, we want to
find the role of the transcription potential.
We found that NIT1 inhibitor remodeling can significantly
increase the anti-PD1 therapy. And in our
clinical sample also showed that higher NIT1, lower MSC1
expression, and lower CD8 cell infiltration.
So let me make a quick summarize of my project.
First, NIT1 is elevated in CRC. NIT1 is linked to MSS,
leads a very terrible CRC type, and the NIT1 promote
autophagy-dependent MSC1 roles.
And the four is interesting story.
A MYC-NIT1 loop exists and to
reinforce this process. The final is targeting
NIT1 enhance the efficacy of PD1 therapy.
So in conclusion, the NIT1-MYC loop drives autophagy-dependent
MSC1 roles and the immune resistance in CRC.
So that's my presentation, and I also want to thank
again,
Professor Ejigo and all my colleagues in my
laboratory helped me a lot and give me encourage, and
sincerely thank Professor Xingxiang Li for giving me so variable
advice and support. And I also want to thank all our
colleagues to help us to finish this project,
especially Dr. Kalagiri and Dr. Yu, Dr. Su.
Thank you very much. I will happy to take any question.
Thank you for this very interesting talk.
We'll wait for some questions from the audience. I think we have one in the back.
Very nice talk. My question is,
in your NIT1 knockout tumor,
did you check the population of macrophage?
Of the macrophage?
So it's a very interesting
question,
because
actually in this autophagy,
have also have the selective in general, and the auto
macrophage is all very important for this process.
But in our previous data, and we
didn't
focus on this part, and I think this,
in the further work, we should finish this part and
support our final story. Thank you.
Thank you.
Great talk. In the interest of time, I think we're going to move to the last talk.
Thank you, Jun Yang.
Thank you so much.
Okay, so our last talk is going to be from Daniel Lagal,
who's from MD Anderson Cancer Center, and he's going to tell us about
reversing resistance to checkpoint inhibition by restoring tumor
matrix signaling.
Take it away, Daniel.
Okay. Thank you so much for this opportunity.
I am Daniel Lagal, and I'm Postdoctoral Fellow at Rush MD
Anderson Cancer Center. I
have nothing to disclose. And I would like to start
this story saying there are different pattern of
T cell infiltration in tumors, as you well know.
These correlate to different response to immunotherapy.
And
our goal here in this
work is to know how
a T cell infiltration fail to infiltrate in
the tumor, right? And also how we can
overcome the immun exclusion phenotype.
So, the immun exclusion phenotype has been always seen
from a tumor-centric perspective.
But here, we have hypothesized that it's actually the
tumor stroma that contribute actively to regulate
the T cell infiltration in the tumors.
There are different strategies that they have
already proven in the field. But
they have limited success, and they fail.
So we need to understand that the tumor
stroma is not a static structure.
Actually, it's dynamic, suffer dynamic
remodeling. And this mimic the wound healing
process. So in the wound healing process, we have at
early stages, a provisional matrix, and this provisional
matrix regulate immunocelle trafficking and activity.
Also in late stages of in wound healing, we
have a fibrotic matrix, and this resemble the
fibrotic tumor stroma that is characterized by
resolution of inflammation and immun exclusion.
So
the fundamental question that we can raise here is
provisional matrix regulate
immunoactivity in the tumors.
So to understand this, the provisional matrix is rich
in proteoglycan, and it's really important during the
embryonic development, but also during the
adult tissue repair.One of these proteoglycans is versican,
that we are going to call here Vcan.
And this is a chondroitin sulfate
proteoglycan that suffers cleavage by ADAMTS.
And this cleavage releases matrikines that are
bioactive fragments that have novelty
function. One of these matrikines is versican.
And this Vcan proteolysis from Vcan to
versican is really important in biology,
because
the mice which they cannot undergo
this
proteolytic cleavage,
they fail to develop cardiovascular system and also
skeletal system. But more visible, as you can see in the
image, they fail to develop
interdigital spaces.
Also, beyond development, Vcan proteolysis regulates the
wound resolution.
The same knockout animals
heal the wound faster.
And this is because we know that Vcan
proteolysis participates in the
wound
healing and prolongs the inflammation
and actually the composition of the wound healing.
So the
question here is clear: Can the same process
act in the same way in the tumor? So well,
there are several
studies that we did, and other lab
did, and the Vcan proteolysis
correlate with CD8 T cell infiltration across solid
and liquid tumor type.
Whenever we have Vcan proteolysis in the tumor stroma,
tumors develop in the tumor core higher infiltration or
cytotoxicity CD8 T cell.
And also,
we know that Vcan proteolysis can be found in
different tumor
types in the patient. But what is more surprising is the
PDAC, that, as you well know, is one of the
more immunosuppressive tumors, Vcan
proteolysis is largely absent.
So we can hypothesize the
tumors, PDAC,
can inhibit the Vcan proteolysis to
generate a less infiltrate tumor microenvironment.
But what is more important is a
recent prospective clinical trial
in colorectal cancer have already
linked Vcan proteolysis to the response of
immunotherapy. So in this clinical trial, the
patient
received radiotherapy,
and also they
received pembrolizumab before and after resection.
And then the patient,
they were categorized in three
phenotypes according to the Vcan proteolysis.
So patient can be VPP, which is versican
proteolysis predominant, and also VPW, which
is versican proteolysis weak,
with low level of Vcan or with high
level of Vcan. And what they found is
the patient that has a VP
phenotype in the
colorectal tumor, they have more infiltration of CD8 as
well as CD4 T cell. And these patients have
better survival rate. In contrast, those
patients that have,
in the colorectal tumor, a phenotype
VPW, Vcan high, they have a
lower survival rate and also
the poorest responses to pembrolizumab.
So therefore, this
clinical trial has linked the Vcan proteolysis
to a better outcome and response to immunotherapy.
But the question here is how Vcan proteolysis regulates
CD8 T cell infiltration. So our previous result
in the
group
conclude that versican, that is
the product of the Vcan proteolysis, colocalizes in the
tumor stroma with CD8 T cells.
And also, in vitro, versican would promote is the CD8 T cell
one generation from FLT3-ligand treated bone
marrow. Versican
help to potentiate the
expression of CD8 T cell-specific transcription factors such as
IRF8 and BARH3. And also in vivo,
versican promote a CD8 T cell survival through
NK-dependent mechanism. So the
LSC-specific tumors that
overexpress versican have more abundance of CD8 T
cells as well as activation. And this is dependent of
NK cell mechanism.
So what we did next, and this is our recent data,
to understand the role of versican in a more
therapeutic
context, we developed a different tumor model
that recapitulatesThose patients,
the different prognostic patient.
So in MC38, which is a VPWV VCAN
low phenotype, whenever we
overexpress versican, this induce a VPV
phenotype that it has a monotherapy effect.
However, in LSC tumor that has a VPWV
VCAN high, when we overexpress versican, this lack
of monotherapy effect,
mimicking this patient that have
more difficult
outcomes.
So we also study different
biopsies from lung carcinoma, and we show the
VPP, that is the versican
proteolyse predominant.
The patients show more CD4, CD8, and also
XR1 cells abundance. But what is more
important is they show immunotriad.
That are those
complexity interaction between CD4
that engage simultaneously with CD8 T-cells and
CD61s. So we have conclude that
versican
generate its effect through the organization of this
immunotriad. And we studied this in MC38
tumors, and when we overexpress versican,
we show higher level of these
immunotriads. Alongside, in this three
subset of this immunotriad, we show more
abundance and activation on the dendritic cell subset,
especially CDC1s,
CD8 T-cell activation, and also CD4
T-cells accumulation. But also we saw
repolarization of this CD4 T-cell towards a
TH1 phenotype with higher expression
of
Tbet transcription factor. So as we
know, these immunotriads
participate actively in the
efficacy of immunotherapy. So,
our question here was to
treat this tumor with different
immunocheckpoint inhibitors.
And we show in MC38 tumor model
that recapitulate those VPWV VCAN low
phenotype. When we overexpress versican with the single
checkpoint inhibition, we show a
robust synergy
of versican with the checkpoint
inhibition. And this cure most of the
animal, and the animal demonstrate durable
immunological memory upon tumor rechallenge.
However, in
LSC tumors that
they have the VPWV VCAN high
phenotype, is necessary versican
overexpression plus dual checkpoint inhibition, and
that is when we show the synergistic effect.
Also, we show a synergistic effect of versican overexpression
with mRITc modulation that is that subset
that is enriched in immunoregulatory
molecules.
So building all these findings,
we treated versican as a exogenous therapeutic
agent. And the key question here is
if we can recapitulate the VCAN
proteolysis endogenous
effect given the
exogenous versican. So we create two different
therapeutic modality through LNP, mRNA, and
also the recombinant protein itself.
And what we show is when we treated the MC38, that
is versican
proteolysis VCAN low levels, we
saw a
monotherapy effect with both
modalities and synergistic effect with
checkpoint inhibition.
Also, as we expect, this
effect of the exogenous versican
it depend
of CDC1 subset and CD8 T-cell, as you
can see here in this experiment with the BARA3 models and also CD8
T-cell depletion.
So as conclusion,
briefly, tumor stroma matrix composition is
heterogeneous. Provisional-like matrix promotes
immunoinfiltration, whereas fibrotic
matrix impedes it. Stromal VCAN proteolysis, a
cardinal event in provisional matrix remodeling, correlate
with CD8 infiltration across multiple solid and liquid
tumor types. In a recent prospective clinical trial for
colorectal cancer, VCAN proteolysis start to
stratify distinct patient subgroup and
predicted responses to checkpoint inhibition immunotherapy.
VCAN proteolysis promotes a stable immunotriad in tumor stroma.
And lastly, the therapeutic delivery of versican, the product
of VCAN proteolysis, is effective, has monotherapy activity,
and synergizes with checkpoint inhibition to
rationally reverse immunosuppression in VCAN proteolysis weak
subgroup.Just briefly, thanks to my
group, my PI, for all the guidance and the mentoring.
My group, my coworkers, Thanos, Duncan, and George,
and our
collaborator. Thank you so much, and happy to take any question.
Great talk, Daniel.
This talk is open for questions now.
While we're waiting to see if there are any questions from the audience,
I can ask a question. Daniel, what do you think is the most obvious
therapeutic opportunity for this approach?
What type of tumors do you think that resistance mediated by this
kind of ECM remodeling is at play in, and where should you target?
Yeah. Thank you so much for the question.
I think this will be proven
in colorectal cancer because it's
the one that is the clinical trial has
already
concluded that there is an effect of VCAM proteolysis with
immuno
CPI. So I think it's a good
starting point to try this
therapeutic modality to deliver versican in this
model because of the pipeline that we
know. But I think in the future,
different tumors can be treated
with this, because I think there are
good
resolution of how
versican is acting and changing the tumor microenvironments,
since we have single cell RNA seq data that conclude
a large modification of the tumor microenvironment and in different
tumor models that are not only
colon, that are also lung carcinoma or other
models.
Very cool.
Thank you.
I have a question.
Thank you, Daniel, for the interesting talk. Tomas Aloto from Argentina.
Taking these results forward, do you think that
armoring CAR T cells, for example, with matrix remodeling
enzymes, could help
enhance the infiltration of the CAR T cells?
Yeah. Thank you for the question. Yeah.
I think it could be a good approach
to add versican in the system.
We didn't prove that yet, but I think it could be a
good future
key to
see this effect also with the CAR T therapy.
So thank you so much for the question. It's a really good one.
I have a follow-up question.
Yeah.
And,
having said that,
do you think that there might be a double-edged sword to that
strategy because
remodeling the matrix could also help tumor cells
disseminate?
Yeah. Thank you so much.
Actually, that question is really good because when I was doing my PhD
in a different lab, I was using
also the tumor stroma remodeling as a
way to understand how the
cell disseminate and create metastasis, right?
Yeah, so that's a really good question.
I think it depends on the mechanism that
you are doing.
Through MMPs, metalloproteinase,
maybe this is more
mechanism to disseminate the cells, but this is what we
are proving is,
one, the matrix is remodeled
through versican. There are inflammation
because it's attracting different subset
of the
different immuno cells, right? So it's not more like
generate a mechanistic
force of the cells to move towards other point.
It's more to create
an environment that is composed of other cells that
help
the T cell infiltration.
Thank you.
Great job, Daniel. And we should mention that Daniel's the recipient of the AACR
Scholar in Training Award for his work.
Thank you so much.
Congratulations,
Daniel. Okay,
and now we conclude the session. I would like to thank all our speakers
for their outstanding presentations, the audience for the great questions,
my co-chair, Robert Manguso, for co-leading the session with me.
I personally learned a lot from this session, and I hope you took
away many ideas and it sparked new collaborations for you as well.
And yeah, I hope you enjoy the rest of your AACR.
Thank you.
Thank you, everyone.
That's great. That was nice.